okay that wasn't loud enough let's try
it again go ahead and talk ignore me hey
ooh awesome good morning you guys my
name is Kristin you've probably gotten
one or two emails from me thank you all
for being here the volunteers and I
they're wearing these awesome Navy
t-shirts we're really excited to teach
you guys engineering concepts through
something used everyday cameras how many
of you guys have a camera phone raise
them higher okay mostly everyone how
about does anyone have Instagram
snapchat nice so I love those things too
but I am also an engineer which is why I
started this program it's a cameras are
this great integration of all these
different technologies computer science
mechanical engineering all sorts of
things and you guys interact with them
every day so it looks like you guys have
gotten your hands on them already and
taken them apart did anything surprise
you on what you found you can talk to
the people next you
girls who okay how about this group over
here did anything surprise you tiny tiny
screws how about that corner in the back
compared to the whole camera great
anything else different from the screws
surprise you guys did anyone have a film
camera was there anything unique about
that I had you ever used one before oh
great so you guys are going to learn a
lot about cameras today and you're even
going to build one yourself but before
we get started I would like to know who
comes to mind when you think of an
engineer or computer scientist so close
your eyes and think about what this
person looks like and what they do
during their day job think about it for
a minute all right open your eyes um
what do you guys think nice how about um
you in the green jacket what do you
think what do they do with the code
anyone think of hacking or Mark
Zuckerberg you guys probably seen him
before right so um those are all really
good examples of what computer
programming is um have you guys seen
iron man before so he does a combination
of computer science and mechanical
engineering but engineering is a lot
more broad than that and ingest camera
technology alone here are some
interesting examples that you might not
normally think about have you guys heard
of unmanned aerial vehicles drones so
so a big thing is putting cameras on
them and they can do things like go
inside a burning building and map it out
for a fireman another example is
high-speed photography for understanding
how animals work or satellite imaging
for figuring out how healthy the earth
is and finally Instagram which you guys
have probably heard of and like i said
before camera technology is not just
about computer science it involves
materials and mechanics and optics and
you guys are going to learn about all
those different components during this
workshop so that leads me to what the
goal of today is you are going to
discover what camera technology is how
to apply it and gain engineering skills
and you're going to do this by building
a camera programming your own Instagram
filters and also learn about
applications of camera technology we
have an awesome lineup of speakers
including space cameras and medical
imaging and we have a bunch of cool
demos at the end including high-speed
photography infrared and 3d scanning so
this is just an overview today we'll
begin with a keynote speaker from chris
clark who all introduced in a minute and
you're going to spend the first half of
the day building a camera you're going
to start off with an introduction to all
the different components of a camera and
then you're going to get your hands on
all the different components and
assemble them and program it to take a
picture when you press the button and
then during lunch we have a panel from
the Society of Women Engineers and the
women's technology program at MIT and in
all girls robotics team so if you're
interested in certain part of today like
you want to do more coding or you want
to do more building you should pay
attention to these programs so they'll
talk about what you can do for longer
they have summer programs and programs
throughout the year and then in the
second half of the day we're going to do
image processing so you're going to get
an introduction to how a computer
understands what and images and how you
can manipulate it with math and make
those real
cool Instagram filters and after you
program your own will have a conclusion
talk about what you learned and finally
we have those really cool demos that I
mentioned before where you'll rotate
around and check them out so you all
received a picture of a famous female
engineer if you didn't get one I have a
bunch of extras for you guys so if you
didn't get one I'm going to start in the
front and just pass them down and take
one okay so you guys are going to be in
teams of four today and those famous
female engineers and computer scientists
are your teams so you're going to work
together on all these challenges and the
volunteers will work with you during
those activities now I have some really
boring details but they are very
important so in case of an emergency
there is stairs in the back so when you
exit turn left and go all the way to the
back and then you cluster outside in the
quad area and there are bathrooms when
you go outside turn left and the
bathroom is on your right and the
volunteers know where they are too if
you have any questions and you guys are
probably interested in this where you
can find the photos afterwards so I
highly encourage you to take as many
photos as possible with your cameras
that you build and they will be posted
on our Facebook page afterwards it's
called girls who built and finally all
the links to the activities that you do
today and the code that you've worked on
and the resources like if you want to
build your own camera at home we'll send
that to you too